-I know you're very busy.
You're all over the place.
You are going to Iowa tomorrow
-Tomorrow.
-You were overheard
by a reporter saying --
And I want to get
the quote right,
because, obviously,
it's a very important state.
-And it's a very important word.
-It's a very important word.
So it's going to get beepe
by the censors,
but it came from an emotional --
not an emotional place.
It came from --
-But it did, actually.
-You said,
"I'm [bleep] moving to Iowa.
-So -- Okay. So let me tell you.
So, I serve on many committees
including the Senate
Judiciary Committee.
And one of my pals on
the Senate Judiciary Committee
is Mazie Hirono,
who is the Senator from Hawaii
She is a -- This will get
beeped, too -- a badass.
-Yeah.
-She is so amazing.
So, I was at the Capitol.
And, you know,
polls go up and down, right?
And, so, I saw Mazie as I wa
walking down the stairs.
It was just she and I.
Or so I thought.
And so I see Mazie.
She gives me a hug.
"Kamala, how are you doing?"
I'm like, "Mazie.
I'm [bleep] moving to Iowa."
-Yeah.
-At which point, it turns ou
there was a journalist
hiding behind the column..
-Yeah. There's
too many columns in D.C.!
-...who then tweeted it.
Right. Exactly.
And now it's, like,
a T-shirt at one of --
at RAYGUN, which is one of the
famous T-shirt stores in Iowa.
And there you are.
-But very important.
You were lucky, though.
Which I think you would
even appreciate that you -
you put the word in question
in the right place.
-Yes. Yes, exactly.
-'Cause if you slide it over..
-It would have been a disaster
-And if you say,
"I'm moving to [bleep] Iowa,
goodbye.
-It would have been a disaster
-Yeah, so you said it right.
It was the enthusiasm.
-And that's how I felt.
I really love being in Iowa.
I have to tell you, I really do.
It's just -- it's --
You know, listen, people are -
They show up at events.
They are serious
about love of country.
They are going to eyeball you.
They want to know,
are you going to talk, you know,
in a way that is relevant?
It's good stuff.
-Well, I think they take i
very seriously.
We've talked about this before
I'm from New Hampshire.
And people there take
very seriously the fact
that politicians are
going to engage with them,
and they have this
very important thing.
I will say, you saying
how much you love Iowa,
and I often hear from
politicians how much they love
New Hampshire. I hear it,
like, every four years.
It's weird.
And then there's, like,
a weird, like, dip.
And then you start hearing again
how much people really love it
-But, you know, but -- No.
But you know why?
Because Iowa,
there is something about -
What I love --
This is what I love about it
I love people
who are just practical
and who are no-nonsense.
And I could say other word
that again would require
a beep, right?
But just who are no-nonsense
And especially
at this moment in time.
People are standing in lin
for two hours
in the cold and the heat.
And when they walk in,
it's 'cause they want to hav
a serious conversation
about the state of our country
But they're also optimisti
enough to be there
and to not, you know,
stay at home thinking
that nothing can get done
or nothing will matter
or that they can't make
a difference.
They know they can make
a difference. I love that.
-Well, that's good
that you are going to be abl
to spend some time there.
You mentioned --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-You mentioned the badassery
of Mazie Hirono.
You also got, um --
You had a badass that I know
very well portray you on "SNL.
I mean, you can do a lot worse
than Maya Rudolph.
I mean --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know.
-That's --
-I know. I know.
-Now, I --
How quickly does that make i
to you as that's happening
Are you getting -- You must be
getting texts in real time
-Well, I mean, first of all,
I grew up watching
"Saturday Night Live."
So the thought that anyone
would be in any way
depicting me
on "Saturday Night Live"
was just --
I was a bit overwhelmed.
But I will tell you
that I fully intend to make sure
she has a good eight years
of work on "SNL."
-Yeah.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's good.
I will tell you --
You know, I, uh --
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, I played
Senator John Kerry in 2004
and, uh, I thought I was
gonna get eight years, too
-That's right.
-I bought the boat
and everything, and, uh...